you know my my bullshit detector
works first of all if there's something
you really want to believe that's what
you should question the most I don't
question bad news very much I don't
question things that go against what I
believe very much but boy the stuff that
I really want to believe I really
questioned a lot I was taught I grew up
as a Christian I suppose at some level I
wanted to believe someone was watching
over me but when I want to believe
something that's when I want to question
the most that's when I have to be the
most careful and I feel a little bit
disingenuous with that answer because I
don't think I need longer want to
believe in God my friend do I miss very
much hitch Christopher Hitchens said
that wanting there to be a God was like
wanting to live in North Korea to give
away all your freedom and for someone
who loves freedom and loves people I
don't think you should hope for God at
all so I guess my detector on God is
that whenever someone uses what they
feel as evidence instead of what they
think as evidence or what they can prove
as evidence I'm very very skeptical the
most important thing is to feel about
things you feel about should feel about
and think about things you should think
about you should not feel about the
speed of light or evolution and you
should not think about love you should
feel I love you you should think about
reality and when someone says they feel
that the universe was created by a god
that's nonsense just like saying you
know I've thought about it and maybe I
should love you don't mix those two and
a lot of people seem to think that that
feeling cheapens the science that if you
feel something it cheapens it
and there's not enough said about how it
cheapens the emotion you know if you're
spending your time feeling that the
earth was created instead of by
intelligent design you should be
spending your time feeling loved feeling
compassion feeling generosity and
loyalty and all the stuff you should
feel in your heart even anger even
disappointment but that doesn't change
the world you should think about the
world and feel about your heart